I'm selling 90 wine on Facebook reels
for my father right now we sold 80 cases
of a 90 barolo on a Facebook reels
marketing execution I'm not sitting up
here guessing I'm not regurgitating what
meta and Snapchat and YouTube are saying
to me I'm not looking at where my margin
is and then selling that to you I'm
living this and then speaking to it and
that's why it's worked for us
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like
[Music]
sounds great
[Applause]
[Music]
it was just earlier this week some 1000
notable signatories came out with an
open letter asking AI labs to pause for
six months and so where do you stand on
that do we need to slow down I don't
think we can slow down if you look at
the history of technology and people
whether it's been the automobile or the
television or the radio or the printing
press new technologies are scary because
they completely change the world I'm
empathetic to why people are trying to
slow down AI because it is one of the
most profound technologies that has ever
happened in the human race I think the
problem is these Technologies are quite
open right the internet the blockchain
these things are open so you come out
and say hey you don't do this AI Labs
but that doesn't stop the 40 000 other
people that are currently working on the
same exact thing and so I I think it's
complex times and this is a very
important point I'm not sure the truth
is I'm really genuinely not sure but I
can tell you this AI will be prevalent
in every single person's lives for the
rest of our lives
well
[Music]
so we're going to Facebook meta
you know dailyvee
um this trip has been really productive
you know it's fun to expand globally
right we've really exploded the Vayner
machine I know a lot of you watch me and
have no clue about the Gary vaynerchuk
part of my life it's all garyvee to you
but like Vayner X we've got eight
companies Latin Canada you know London
Amsterdam everything that's going on in
aipac here in Singapore beautiful
country by the way you should absolutely
come I think the most exciting part is
sensing that APAC is building that what
we're going to do and like that I'll be
in Tokyo a lot that what we're doing in
Australia I can't wait to be in
Australia first week of Australia see
all you [__] in Australia in August
so anyway thank you
hello hi thanks for coming thank you so
much the framework for me doing social
brand building and building businesses
is what's the brand stand for what's the
business objective the next thing we do
is we create 40 to 50 consumer
segmentations 18 to 22 year old males
living in Bangladesh that are into
Esports 21 to 27 year old females in
Tokyo making 200 000 a year 40 to 45
year old moms in Malaysia who have an
affinity towards High fashion real
specific consumer cohorts with real
teeth next on that is called pack
platforms and culture like do you
actually understand what the platforms
are doing next which platforms are you
creating for you lay out the platforms
then you go to work so now you create a
framework now the work really begins
after you make you have a person your
strategy team called the PCS a
post-creative strategist her and his job
is to look at all the qualitative
feedback you have your analytics and
media team look at the quantity back and
you start making your machine smart the
team gets smart through the work as you
start getting affirmation that
something's not working you actually
eliminate Malaysian moms 40 45 because
you aren't finding Affinity your
creative team hasn't hit the mark on the
flip side while marketing to Indonesia
Gamers 13 to 15. you realize it's
actually the female Gamers 13 to 15 that
are even more interested in the intent
and you create a new cohort to go there
to double down on the truth of the
consumer not the audacity of the board
group that's how I do it
we have a really special guest with us
today we are so honored and thrilled to
have with us the one and only garyvee
[Applause]
I think it's different about me than a
lot of the people that do what I do for
a living is I'm a practitioner of The
Craft when I say you can sell eighty
dollar stuff I'm selling 90 wine on
Facebook reels for my father right now
as we sit here today we sold 80 cases of
a 90 barolo on a Facebook reels
marketing execution I'm not sitting up
here guessing I'm not regurgitating what
meta and Snapchat and YouTube are saying
to me I'm not looking at where my margin
is and then selling that to you I'm
living this and then speaking to it and
that's why it's worked for us
[Music]
another introduce ourselves because my
husband I'm Joyce from the BSU such a
pleasure such a pleasure advice from the
strategy team it's such a pleasure thank
you
it's such a pleasure
you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa what was it right now I'm just
managing a bunch of like editors on the
beat I'm ready to step up to be a leader
why do you think makes a good leader two
things one someone who understands the
crap of what we're doing and two someone
who cares about the people that work for
them more than they care about the
advancement of their own career right if
you are able to actually care about them
more than you care about yourself by
Nature you become a great leader and
then third someone who motivates their
team with love and optimism not with
fear and hate
[Music]
I always wonder like have you met people
who like you know how they juggle work
and like you know because a lot of women
like I said my last company and I don't
want to do that you know one of the
things I'm most proud of is I think
we're incredibly strong at having
policies that are incredibly supportive
yeah I think it's very achievable what I
can promise you since I'm the CEO of
this company you taking time for that
won't hurt your career you won't be
penalized for the most beautiful thing
you can do yeah
I know
of course I know yeah of course so
that's why I'd like to think that you
can already sense that that is not our
DNA for sure and I always tell my
husband that's like I'll
for our business the longer people stay
here the better we'll be at what we do
yeah and for me that goes back to if you
do the right thing the right things will
happen I want people to stay here for as
long as possible and if we create a
great culture then they will and so you
know I appreciate that I'm happy for you
[Music]